Good morning everyone, flight
time today is six hours,
fifty four mintues and we wish
you a safe and pleasant flight.
Everybody down.
Highjack is about a plane that
leaves from Dubai to London,
the planes being hiijacked.
Stay in your seats.
And it's not clear why.
[Stuart] Operation has
commenced.
I play Sam Nelson.
Sam is an ordinary man in an
extrordinary situation.
He's a very successful
business negotiator.
And he's driven to
get back home.
I just want to get home
to my family.
I wanted to shoot this show as
close to being in a real
hijack situation as possible.
We've brought in a real plane.
It had to feel like you were
really there with the passangers
and that you were really
experincing that moment.
Bam! Until you know who these
people are do nothing.
We had the shell of a cockpit
connected to a flight simulator.
All of the computer displays
in the flight deck are as
realistic as possible.
The integration of the volume
screen is one of the cutting
edge aspects of our industry at
the moment. It helps create
a level of authenticity
for the audience.
The lights move past the windows
at the same speed and angle
as the sun really passes the
windows of plane
flying from Dubai.
We've paid attention
to every last detail.
There's a ticking clock to tell
a real time thriller
over seven hours on the plane
heading twords London.
Each episode is a play by play
of what happens on the plane.
We are second by second, minute
by minute, hours by hours,
edge of your seat.
[Passanger] Get the gun.
Don't make them do this.
There's more and more tension,
twist and turns.
It's a hell of a
rollercoaster ride.
Intense adrenaline, you are a
passanger on that plane.
Sit down in your seat and buckle
up your seatbelt.